Netflix Anime Mega-Rich Two-Hour Special!
Good evening, everyone! Thank you for tuning in.
I’m today’s MC, Tenshin Mukai.
Thank you!
Today we’re presenting a “mega-rich” number of Netflix anime titles!
That includes hot current titles and brand new ones.
We’re streaming on the Netflix Anime Twitter and YouTube accounts.
And we’ll be archived for everyone to enjoy!
Let’s introduce our guests, representing all these great Netflix Anime titles!
Hello, I’m Haruka Shiraishi.
I play Yuri in High-Rise Invasion.
I’m so happy to be here!
And nervous! Thank you!
Next, Kaji-san.
Hi, I’m Yuki Kaji.
I play Koku in B: The Beginning Succession.
Finally season 2 is here for you all to enjoy.
Let’s have fun today!
Next, Tsuda-san.
Hi, I’m Kenjiro Tsuda.
I play Tatsu in The Way of the Househusband.
-I’m nervous!
-No way!
Next, Kohno-san.
Hi, I’m Marika Kohno. I play Sara in Eden.
-I’m nervous too!
-Everyone's saying that!
Next, Shimazaki-san.
Hi, I’m Nobunaga Shimazaki.
I play Baki Hanma in BAKI.
You seem a bit nervous.
The title and the character are the same.
There’s no mixing it up!
Last but not least, Kobayashi-san.
Hi, I’m Chiaki Kobayashi. I play Yu Ominae,
a member of Spriggan in Spriggan.
Thank you all for today.
We’ll be hearing a lot more about your titles over the next two hours.
We’ve got a lot of distance here on stage.
I can barely see Kobayashi-san.
Let’s still try to enjoy the space.
Tsuda-san, you aren’t really nervous, right?
-I am! I am!
-Your posture is so relaxed!
My heart is beating.
A great lineup here on stage today.
You’ve all been in multiple titles, but is anyone meeting for the first time?
Yes, it’s my first time to meet a lot of you!
Me too. Some I’ve met, but haven’t worked together before.
Well, we’ll all become friends today, especially at the end.
Lots of people I’ve only seen on TV. I kind of feel like a fan!
Let’s get to know each other while introducing these series.
Kaji-san, hello to you too.
Such an amazing set, but with lots of social distance.
We’ll have to raise our voices!
Right, there’s a lot of plastic walls to overcome!
Let’s really go for it, everyone!
Such volume!
Let’s do it with that passion the whole way through.
Please stick with us until the end.
Here’s our first title.
Streaming worldwide,
it’s High-Rise Invasion, starring Shiraishi-san.
First, let’s take a look at this clip!
I will kill the Mask!
Big brother,
help me!
I'm on the roof of a building.
There's a strange man with a mask on.
The Mask is there?
I won't die without seeing my big brother!
That's the rule of this world. Accept it.
The Mask's aim is to drive people
to suicide from despair.
Is there really a human being
inside the Mask?
May I speak to you?
This realm is an institution
that creates Gods.
What on earth?
What is "Become a God"?
My name is Kazuma Aohara.
Could I say that
I am God Candidate within this realm?
I cannot defy the Mask's orders.
Do you know how to access
the Railgun System?
I want to bring true peace to the world.
If you behave disrespectfully,
you will have to die.
I dare you to do it, you fiend!
I want to die with you!
Mayuko!
You better not direct
your hostility at me.
I'll become God.
I am right about everything!
Anything that they desire.
I will wipe them out, no matter what!
I am going to die.
Die?
I will not die!
Wow, quite a thrilling clip.
My palms are sweating.
“Don’t think, despair.
Screw the rules, break them instead!”
-A pretty impressive slogan!
-Quite strong!
A series about a gruesome game of death
from Ajin’s Tsuina Miura and Box!’s Takahiro Oba.
Not just a game of death! A gruesome one!
Shiraishi-san, tell us a bit about the show and your character, Yuri Honjo.
Like you said, there’s despair from the beginning.
The characters can’t come down from
the high rises, and different Masks attack them.
How can the characters survive their brutal circumstances?
Yuri loves her brother, and really wants to see him again.
But there are so many different Masks! Some perverted ones, even!
Some Masks maintain what they were good at when they were human.
Swimming, baseball, etc.
So they attack in various ways. That’s part of the fun.
How will the characters survive? Who can they trust?
Please check it out.
Right, the Masks all attack in different ways.
Yuri figures out ways to battle them every time.
That’s part of what makes her great.
How about her friend Nise?
It seems like she really likes Yuri.
They have such a nice relationship.
It’s a serious show, but with some surreal humor.
That’s fun too.
Thank you!
Next, some key phrases based on a pre-interview with Shiraishi-san.
Do any of these phrases pique your interest, Kaji-san?
They’re all interesting, but…
What about the scariest Mask?
There were a lot in the trailer.
How about it, Shiraishi-san?
Here it comes.
-Is it us?
-No, here it is.
The first mask Yuri encounters, right when she wakes up.
-So scary!
-Right?
The scene is so powerful.
When I read the manga I thought it was so scary.
And anime makes it even more real.
In a good way, it’s so scary and thrilling.
-It would be terrible to meet that Mask!
-Right?!
-He’s the first enemy?
-Yes!
-Wielding a Japanese sword! So scary!
-And there are many more!
Let’s ask more! Kaji-san, go ahead.
It sounds like a very scary world,
but any scenes you empathize with?
Especially in terms of Yuri?
It’s quite a scary world.
I asked myself what I would do if I were there.
I’m not as strong as Yuri, but she has
a strong goal to see her brother and escape.
I also move toward goals with a sense of purpose.
I could really sympathize with that.
Keeping her cool in serious situations.
It’s not just serious, though.
Nise-chan is a bit of a tsundere.
But she opens herself up to Yuri.
She wants to hug but worries about not having showered, etc.
She’s so cute.
Even among serious scenes there’s comical parts.
Speaking of High-Rise Invasion, we asked the whole group one more question.
“Which guest here today is closest to God status?”
Probably the first and last time you’ll ever be asked that!
Let’s see the results!
Wow, four people picked Tsuda-san.
Shirashi-san, why Tsuda-san?
I’d known about Tsuda-san for a long time, and it was exciting to work with him.
When he’s acting in front of me, it’s so thrilling.
He’s like a god of acting.
-A god of acting!
-Thank you!
Three more people! Kaji-san?
Just look at him, he’s a god!
If I were a god, I’m ask him to make me a voice actor!
Two gods, huh?
He’s so good at acting, he’s a god.
And he gives such specific advice.
We once ate together and he gave me
some advice on something I was worried about.
-I’m still thankful to him.
-Anytime!
Shimazaki-san?
His sex appeal.
Even as a fellow guy, he’s so sexy. And humorous.
-A sexy god.
-Yeah, so cool.
Kobayashi-san?
He ticks all the boxes for my ideal guy image.
Like his beard, and of course his voice.
Tsuda-san, you’re being praised a lot here.
-Well, I'm closest to heaven in terms of age.
-No, no, not that!
We’ll be asking questions like this for all the shows.
Stay tuned.
The answers we didn’t have time
for will be uploaded to Netflix’s social media!
High-Rise Invasion is now streaming worldwide!
Please check it out!
Next up is...
B: The Beginning Succession, starring Kaji-san.
It just started streaming last month.
First, let’s check out this trailer!
Koku, we need
your blade and your power.
You survived?
Then what about all the others?
So let's do this together.
If you don't accept my offer,
they'll all die.
Wiped out
like they were never here.
After all my searching,
I found you, Koku.
No. Killer B.
Citizens have already begun
to voice their fears
about the dangers
of serial murders starting up again.
Mother of God!
Lily, go find Keith.
Yeah, I'm on it.
So this was a trap.
Keith has been kidnapped.
Then it's vengeance.
Those who kill God
will become devils,
whereas devil killers
become kings.
Be careful, everyone!
There are still a great many things
that you remain ignorant to.
Every scene is so cool
I’ve got goosebumps.
It’s directed by Kazuto Nakazawa,
who worked on titles like Kill Bill. It’s animated at Production I.G.
B: The Beginning has won worldwide acclaim.
It was even featured at the 42nd Annecy Animation Film Festival!
Now the second season is finally here!
The theme song is performed by ACCAMER!
Kaji-san, what can you tell us about the show and your character, Koku?
It’s a complicated story, so I’m not sure where to start.
Succession is season 2 of the show.
Season 1 ended with the possibility of a continuation.
Keith on the police side, played by Hiroaki Hirata, and me as Koku on the other side.
A good balance.
A key word in the show is “B,” with a unique logo.
It appears at the murder scenes each time, along with a four-fingered slash.
It’s the mark of Killer B.
Season 1 was about who Killer B was.
It was actually Koku, who I play.
“B” meant “13,” and the “4” flash represented Yuna, who he searched for.
It’s like a psycho-suspense with battle fantasy.
It tries a lot of new things in the world of anime.
Battles, mysteries… it’s a great show.
Next, some key phrases based on a pre-interview with Kaji-san.
Tsuda-san, do any of these words pique your interest?
So many amazing scenes, but how about your favorite scene?
There are lots of scenes, but what’s your favorite?
Well, there are lots.. battles, great animation.
But my favorite are those with Keith, played by Hirata-san.
It’s like watching a TV series from abroad.
His voice and acting are so good.
It’s anime but it feels like reality.
Sometimes Hirata-san’s lines are 2-3 pages at a time!
Keith is called Genie, or “genius,” in the show.
I really love his long lines.
But when Hirata-san looks at those long lines,
he says “can I take a break next week?”
“I’ll give half the lines to you.”
He’s a charming guy, not just cool.
Hirata-san really brings out the charm of that character.
That adds even more charm to the show!
One more, Tsuda-san?
-Which character would be a great partner?
-Out of all the RIS characters?
There’s a character called Kaela.
She’s at HQ, as a navigator.
There are lots of computers in front of her,
and she even uses her feet to operate them!
Wow, like an instrument?
It’s so cool, I would love to have her as support.
You could succeed even if you weren’t that good yourself.
She might be the best partner.
Wow, using her feet, it’s like playing drums!
There are lots of unique characters.
Please give it a watch.
Speaking of B: The Beginning Succession, we asked the group one more question.
"Which guest might have an unexpected side?"
Let’s see the answers.
Two people chose Shiraishi-san.
Let’s ask about her.
Tsuda-san?
She’s always smiling. I’ve never seen her angry.
I bet she’d be really scary when angry.
-This isn’t really praise, is it?
-But you did say she’s nice.
Do you get angry?
I’m not sure how I’d be if I really got mad.
It might happen sometime?
Yikes, don’t get her angry!
Kobayashi-san, how about you?
We haven't really met, this is just my impression.
But when I searched online she was smiling a lot.
She seems like she has enough courage to even smash bugs while smiling!
Even to catch cockroaches with a smile!
-Can you do that?
-No way!
-Oh, she got a bit angry just now!
-She might come for me!
-Shiraishi-san, you chose Tsuda-san?
-Yes, I chose him again.
He plays cool characters, but when we met he was so nice.
He really cheers you on. That’s different from his persona.
-I’m getting praised again!
-It’s becoming a theme!
He likes tapioca milk tea, too.
He’s a bit cute. Not just cool.
Why all this praise?
Today’s a Tsuda-san praise fest!
It’s interesting to think about these persona gaps!
Might give our viewers food for thought.
B: The Beginning Succession is now streaming worldwide!
Check it out along with season 1!
Okay, let’s move onto the next title.
Starring Tsuda-san and coming to Netflix
April 8 worldwide, it’s The Way of the Househusband!
First, let’s check out the trailer!
Once,
there was a legendary yakuza,
feared in the world
of organized crime.
The Immortal Dragon.
However, one day,
the man vanished without a trace
and is now…
Occupation?
Full-time househusband.
For the family I love,
I will weather
the Way of the Househusband!
This is uncut, 100% hand-sewn.
Come on, just buy it!
I won't buy you games
if you act like a spoiled brat!
Hamburger meal.
Don't you know
light and dark laundry doesn't mix!
Don't mess with color transfer!
Why aren't you
attacking the corner?
Boss!
Huh?
Why'd you quit being a yakuza?
Hey!
I'm going to protect my own
in my own way.
You forgot your lunch!
Daily chores
just became a little more fun
in this cozy comedy
exclusively available on NETFLIX.
NETFLIX is seriously
raking in the dough.
The Way of the Househusband.
I'll pay whatever it takes.
Just prepare the goods.
Also, could you make
a point card for me?
It looks so funny!
Even from the trailer!
The hit manga by Kosuke Oono with over 3.6 million
copies in print is now an anime series!
Legendary former yakuza member Tatsu
is now a househusband in this domestic comedy!
Tsuda-san joined our AnimeJapan special last week.
It looked like a lot of fun!
Tsuda-san, what can you tell us about the show and your character, Tatsu?
Well, just as you saw,
he’s a legendary former yakuza who becomes a househusband.
He runs into all the usual problems with household chores.
It’s a domestic gag anime. It’s quite funny.
Even the pictures here are so funny.
You can really enjoy it casually.
It’s got a great cast lineup.
How was the recording?
Because of the pandemic, we all record separately.
Lots of studios on the same floor.
I do a few episodes on the same day.
Just me in a big booth for three.
A bit lonesome, but the show is interesting so I laugh a lot.
I could just keep going. So fun.
Next, some key phrases based on a pre-interview with Tsuda-san.
Kohno-san, do any of these words pique your interest?
“Pulling potatoes!”
You don’t hear this much in everyday conversation.
It must be a yazuka phrase?
I just had to look it up!
When you pull up a potato, your body language looks as if you’re scared!
Right!
Tsuda-san, any “pulling potato” moments?
Quite a phrase, right?
“Getting scared” or “freaking out.”
For example, I sometimes go to the wrong studio.
I go where I think the recording is and get there early.
Have a coffee, take it easy.
I go in five minutes beforehand.
But then it’s the wrong place!
-What?
-Never happens to you guys?!
-It does.
-Right?!
Not all the time, of course. Sometimes.
I did it 3 times the other day!
I went to all the wrong rooms in the same studio!
Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Then finally made it to the right place.
-You do get scared when you get it wrong.
-A "pulling potato" moment.
Kohno-san, anything else?
I think Tsuda-san is so friendly,
so I wonder if he has anything in common with Tatsu?
Well, not really.
His voice, I guess.
-Of course!
-It’s you!
Well, when I meet younger people for the first time, they don’t talk to me.
Tatsu and I might look hard to talk to.
You do look scary. You aren’t, though.
You have that god-like aura. Hard to approach.
-Let's grab a bite soon.
-Oh, thank you!
-That might be one thing in common.
-Right. Please talk to me, everyone.
Speaking of The Way of the Househusband, we asked the whole group one more question.
“Which guest seems best at household chores?”
Let’s see the answers.
Two people answered Kobayashi-san.
Tsuda-san?
-It seems like you can do anything.
-Based on what?
-Your atmosphere.
-Atmosphere!
-You look like a chores (kaji) advisor!
-Do I?
-An advisor for Kaji-san?
-Kaji-kun, you chose yourself?
Right, I chose myself because “kaji” means chores!
No deep meaning!
I thought someone might make that joke.
I felt like I had to!
Koyabashi-kun, why do you look so Kaji-like?
Even though you’re not Kaji!
-Sorry!
-No need to apologize!
I should look less like I can do chores!
Kohno-san, why Kobayashi-san?
-Just based on his face.
-Is my face that Kaji-like?!
We’ve never met, so I looked him up.
The first picture looked like a guy who knows chores!
Thank you!
-How about in reality?
-I like cleaning.
But I can’t cook.
I can’t even make rice.
I've never bought a rice cooker.
You have a house, right?!
Yes, with electricity and everything.
But rice cookers are hard to use.
Don’t you just press the button?
-I’ve tried it many times, but it was soaked.
-Too much water!
-Just use trial and error!
-Nah, it’s quite hard.
This is the guy picked as “best at chores”!
Kobayashi-san, please do try your hand at rice cooking.
I’ll try to live up to my chores face.
The Way of the Househusband starts streaming worldwide April 8!
Check it out!
And here’s our next title!
Coming May 27 and starring Kohno-san, it’s Eden!
Let’s take a look at this trailer!
Human language.
There is a human in this world.
What would you like to do?
Eliminate them.
No one must know
there is a human here.
Humans are considered to be bad.
Sara!
Did the recon squad find out
about this place?
What are you going to do?
Stop Zero!
Zero, are you fully recharged?
Humans will destroy the world.
They are evil.
Humans are not harmful!
Sara is a very good human.
Stop!
Why do you hate humans
so much?
To create a perfect world,
humans are a hindrance.
It can't be…
Wow, what a trailer.
It was unveiled at AnimeJapan, with Kohno-san in attendance.
It really leaves you guessing!
Yes, it’s an original anime, so no one knows what’s coming!
As you heard in the trailer, “humans are evil.”
There’s a battle between robots and Sara, a human.
-She goes on a journey for the truth.
-Looks fascinating.
Eden is directed by Yasuhiro Irie (Fullmetal Alchemist: Brotherhood),
and features the work of top creators worldwide!
It’s a heartwarming sci-fi fantasy.
Kohno-san, what can you tell us about the show and your character, Sara?
My character, Sara, was raised by two robots.
They can’t speak at first. They’re farmer robots who pick apples.
Sara was raised by those robots. In this world, there are only robots.
Why is Sara the only human, where did the rest go?
She goes on an adventure to find out.
I can’t wait to see it!
Next, some key phrases based on a pre-interview with Kohno-san.
Shimazaki-san, do any of these words pique your interest?
How about working with veteran voice actor Koichi Yamadera?
How was it?
He’s like a senpai for all of us.
We recorded it a while back, in 2017-2018.
I was new, and didn’t know much about voice recording.
What was acceptable and what wasn’t.
Zero is played by Yamadera-san.
He’s a robot, but in one scene he drinks then talks.
It’s a very important scene.
In the test, Yamadera-san drank his own water then spoke.
I thought, “I see, you can do that!”
Right in front of the mic.
It was a great learning experience.
Right, you’re not sure you can do it.
Of course, it worked because it was Yamadera-san.
If it were me I wouldn’t be sure what to do with the cup!
I thought he was so cool.
-What a great learning experience. So nice.
-Indeed.
Next, Shimazaki-san?
Hm, how about “warm feeling”?
Or maybe “Eden”?
Well, I’m not sure how to answer “Eden,” so “warm feeling.”
-I don’t really do cooking...
-This sounds like a job for Kobayashi-san! Not!
So, I use a delivery service to order food.
In the app, you can help support restaurants.
You can add a kind of tip.
I added some extra money.
Inside my order was a handwritten message thanking me for the support.
Okay, it sounds a bit silly to be satisfied
just by giving someone some money...
But it did make me feel happy about helping someone out.
That would give you a warm feeling.
Handwritten letters are so nice.
I get them from fans too, there’s so much love in them.
Much different from a printed letter.
Those are nice too, of course.
Speaking of Eden, we’ve asked everyone one more question.
“Which guest could most easily adapt to another world?”
Let’s see the answers.
Three people chose Kaji-san.
Shiraishi-san, why Kaji-san?
Based on the characters he plays,
he seems like he could really survive.
Thank you!
Until now, it’s basically been Tsuda-san!
I thought I’d get chosen for the chores (kaji)!
Shimazaki-san?
He’s so flexible and adaptable.
He can do anything, but also thinks of others.
He creates a great environment everywhere.
-He’s so deliberate.
-Right!
I understand why Tsuda-san just said he’d buy me a meal…
-I didn’t say “buy”!
-Oh! Oops! Thank you, everyone.
Kobayashi-san?
Kaji-san’s been in so much anime, surrounded by Titans, or by breasts!
He won’t be so surprised by anything.
-He has so much experience
-Right.
Yes, I have been in many genres…
But I chose Tsuda-san for that reason.
-So much life experience.
-Is that praise?!
But you can learn from him as a person and as an actor. So cool.
But it looks like they’re telling us to move on!
Yes! But there are more questions! Please praise him then!
Eden hits Netflix worldwide starting May 27!
Check it out!
Here’s our next title!
Baki Hanma, starring Shimazaki-san.
First, let’s check out this teaser!
Fight me.
PRACTICAL SHADOW FIGHTING
PRISON BATTLE
WILDMAN WAR
THE PICKLE WARS
STRONGEST FATHER-SON BATTLE IN HISTORY
THE WORLD IS WAITING
I'm going to go all out.
It’s the climax of BAKI.
The strongest father-son battle in history!
Baki Hanma, smashing onto Netflix worldwide in 2021!
Finally, Baki Hanma in anime form.
There are a lot of crazy looking opponents.
I’m sure fans of the manga are looking forward to seeing it on screen!
Shimazaki-san, what can you tell us about this season?
Well, Yujiro Hanma is known as the world’s strongest creature.
Played wonderfully by Akio Otsuka.
He’s so strong he can create treaties between countries with his might alone.
Every satellite is tracking him, so GPS itself gets thrown off when he moves!
-Such power!
-Right?
That means his son, Baki, has had a tough life!
Oh, here’s some key art drawn by Itagaki-sensei.
The series tracks Baki’s changes and growth.
The stories are so wild they seem like lies!
The cast is great too.
When we did the previous season, Tsuda-san was in it.
There were five leads, and he was the youngest!
In other words, the gods above the gods!
So many amazing voices. So husky.
The show is so fun both visually and aurally.
Next, some key phrases based on a pre-interview with Shimazaki-san.
Lots of great keywords…
Here’s something from director Toshiki Hirano.
Whoa, I didn’t know about this.
It’s a surprise message from director Hirano.
Let me read it out.
“You’ve reached the same level as Otsuka-san.
Great work. You’ve surpassed my expectations.”
He’s really praising you!
It’s really wild this time!
The main fight is with Biscuit Oliva, who has so much muscle!
He’s played by Hochu Otsuka.
He’s not just cool, but charming.
I have to work hard to even get close to his level!
The director says you’re on the same level!
I’m so happy!
I can’t wait to see this!
Kobayashi-san, how about these keywords?
How about “sum it up in one word”?
Muscles! It’s all about muscles!
Biscuit has so many muscles.
He says, “there’s hidden muscle within me.”
If I release all my muscles, they’ll bust through the walls and to heaven!
BAKI’s so crazy!
But Baki says, “no, no way.”
But Hochu-san is so persuasive. He convinces Baki.
But that’s how important muscles are this time.
-I can’t wait!
-It’s definitely exciting!
Speaking of Baki Hanma, we’ve asked everyone to fill in these blanks.
“Out of everyone here, (blank) is really strong at (blank).”
Let’s see the answers!
Kohno-san and Tsuda-san got two picks each.
Shiraishi-san, you picked Kohno-san.
She’s just so cute.
The first time we met, I was blown away by her cute voice.
Like a twittering bird.
-And she’s so beautiful.
-No, no!
-Cuteness is strength!
-Right!
Everyone’s full of praise today!
I picked Shiraishi-san for the “god” question.
I was a minor character on a show she starred in.
During the break, she came and talked to me.
It’s not so common for minor and main characters to talk.
Main actors are usually so busy.
But Shiraishi-san came and talked to me. So compassionate!
-”Compassionate!”
-You don’t hear that much!
She’s like an angel!
Tsuda-san, you chose Kohno-san.
She seems really strong at video games.
Thank you! I’m so happy!
There are a lot of voice actors who love games.
I’m so happy Tsuda-san noticed me!
-How nice!
-Yeah!
Kaji-san, you chose Tsuda-san, of course!
I might talk so much we’d have no time for Spriggan!
I mean, I already called him a god!
-Right, gods are powerful!
-Right!
-Who else picked Tsuda-san?
-Kohno-san.
-Tsuda-san is so great.
-Compassionate?
Yes! I always ask my senpais for advice. Tsuda-san praised me for that.
She even asked Tessho Genda-san for advice! So great!
You like to involve everyone!
Yes, I asked Genda-san for some narration advice.
Tsuda-san is so good at praise, and watches everyone thoroughly.
He made me so happy.
It feels like Tsuda-san is everyone’s god.
We’ve also got a godly MC!
No, no! They’re telling me to hurry up!
Baki Hanma hits Netflix worldwide in 2021!
Check out the previous seasons streaming now and look forward to it!
Here is the next show
we're showing you today!
Here exists a single tablet.
Beings
of an ancient civilization,
whose great advances
resulted in their downfall,
relayed a warning
to the present generation
through this notice.
They wrote,
"Protect our legacy
from evildoers."
An organization sincerely
accepted this message
and actively seeks to keep
the ancient civilization sealed.
And the special agents
of that organization...
are called "Spriggan."
There you have it.
Spriggan finally
gets an anime adaptation.
Spriggan, started in 1989
in Shogakukan’s Weekly Shonen Sunday,
and created by Hiroshi Takashige
and Ryoji Minagawa,
leaps onto the screen 30 years later
with a vivid blend of 2D and 3D animation!
It’s a high-tempo, battle action series
revolving around ancient ruins!
Kobayashi-san, I’m sure there’s a lot
you can’t reveal yet.
If there's anything you can tell us...
How about your character, Yu Ominae,
and the series?
The narration explained a little bit
but Spriggan is a team
that seals ancient artifacts.
They're the ARCAM corporation.
Spriggan are the cream of the crop agents
who protect the artifacts.
The Spriggan fight bad guys that come after the artifacts
and bad guys from all different countries.
It's a sci-fi battle series.
But are Spriggan and ARCAM Corporation,
trying to seal the artifacts, the good guys?
Are the enemies really evil?
The series touches on that
and is really deep.
I see.
I'm sure many viewers will
take an interest hearing this.
The cast was only just announced recently.
You said recording
sessions have been “throat-crushing”!
Are the scenes pretty intense?
I usually look like the upper right face.
What? Not the face in the middle?
Yu only looks like that
a few seconds every episode.
So he's mostly shouting?
He's shouting or talking with an attitude.
What?
That's his character.
-He does?
-Yes.
It must be tough
but an awesome role to play?
Absolutely. We haven't announced
the rest of the cast yet
but we have many experienced
voice actors on the cast.
I have much to learn
working together with them.
It's a wonderful experience.
I see. We have put together
another board of keywords.
Let's take a look.
Shiraishi-san,
please choose from the five keywords.
-Yes.
-Please choose one.
This is such a big title.
As a fellow voice actor,
I'd like to ask about the audition.
Of course. How was the audition?
-I auditioned for Yu and another role.
-You did?
I've never done a role like Yu
who's always shouting.
I thought if I were going to get a role,
it would be the other role.
Instead I got Yu, so I was shocked.
-It happens.
-It does?
-Right?
-Yeah.
You get the least expected roles.
And you don't get the roles you
felt confident auditioning for.
Maybe you're more relaxed
or less calculated.
When you're confident,
it's going as you planned.
-I see.
-Yeah.
Maybe that's why it's no good.
It's not that it's no good.
You got the role.
You did a great job at acting.
I had fun playing both roles.
-I see.
-It was just surprising I got Yu.
Now it will open a new path
for you as an actor.
It's a wonderful thing.
Shiraishi-san. Next question, please.
-Which word?
-Let me see.
-Memorable characters, please.
-Sure.
Perhaps this is based on
reading the original manga.
Are there any memorable characters
besides Yu?
The enemies in Spriggan
are all full of appeal.
I especially like Iwao Akatsuki.
He's a really nice, bulky guy.
Well, most of them are.
-Of course. Being a special agent.
-Right.
He is your quintessential enemy
and so cut-throat.
He just wants to kill Yu.
But he sometimes shows his nice side and helps Yu out.
He even has cute banter with the heroine
and shows a sense of humor.
I love that side of him.
I also had a chance to record with
the voice actor who plays Akatsuki.
I can't reveal who the cast is yet.
But his acting is amazing.
Due to COVID-19 we recorded alone.
It ended up being a unique experience for me.
I got to chat with the person who
plays my enemy during our break.
We really got to develop
a bond, which is rare.
It makes Akatsuki
all the more special to me.
So the character and the actor is special.
Now we can't wait to find out who the cast is.
It's time to praise one another yet again.
Speaking of Spriggan,
we also asked our cast,
Who among today’s cast do you think has special powers?
What would that power be?
Let's take a look at the answers.
This is strange.
Shimazaki-san pointed to everyone.
That's why there are so many lines.
Let's ask why he pointed to everyone.
It's our voice acting skills.
I think it's an amazing skill,
and I don't mean it as a joke.
I really think
that the skills of voice actors are unique.
It's something we can be proud of
and we are each recognized actors.
I think we all have a special skill
in that sense.
Watching this show makes me feel so happy.
You all have something nice
to say about each other.
You're right.
Voice acting skills are a special skill.
Who else shall I ask?
-Kaji-san chose Shimazaki-san?
-Yes.
-I've nothing to add.
-Knock it off!
You praise one another and that's it?
What more can I say?
-On top of that.
-On top?
I chose Nobunaga-kun.
He's a little weird.
-Weird?
-Does that count as a special skill?
He hasn't outgrown his childishness.
I probably haven't either.
He enjoys it and uses it
as his strength in his work.
It adds to his special skills
as a voice actor, so I chose him.
I know.
I'm ready.
-Nice.
-What skill is that?
That's a special skill.
-He didn't need sound effects?
-Incredible.
But he wasn't Baki.
You really do have special skills.
Incredible.
I wanted to ask more but alas!
We've been on air for over an hour.
How time flies!
On to the next segment.
Spriggan will be streamed
worldwide in 2021!
Let’s look forward to it!
From here we're going to
change the swing of things.
We're going to do a games segment.
No we're not. I made a boo boo.
I was in such a rush
I almost skipped an entire segment.
Aside from titles
that our guests tonight are starring in,
Netflix has a mega-rich lineup of anime
to look forward to.
We have three titles to preview today.
First, we have Yasuke.
Let’s watch this trailer
just released on April 2.
Set in feudal Japan,
it is about Yasuke,
the first African to become a samurai.
He decides to pick up his sword once more
to protect a girl with mysterious powers
from dark forces.
Netflix Original Series Yasuke
will stream worldwide
starting Thursday,
April 29, 2021.
Next is Record of Ragnarok.
Please take a look at this clip.
Thirteen one-on-one matches
between gods and men
will take place
Thirteen one-on-one matches
"Ragnarok."
You wish not to stand
in the same ring as me?
Are you perhaps
scared?
There is no one in this world
who can rival me
I have one request.
Do not die.
You're a nasty one, aren't you?
Don't look at me,
you perverted old man.
For the first time in millennia,
my blood is running hot.
I'm getting excited.
File number one.
It's sour.
Ganryu is still evolving.
Sounds like fun.
I'm so jealous of that human.
This is a fight for the soul.
Crush him.
They're all trash.
The mega-hit manga finally
gets an anime adaptation!
The curtain opens on the ultimate showdown
between gods and humans
whose one-on-one battles will determine
the survival of mankind!!
Netflix original anime series
Record of Ragnarok
will stream from June 2021!
What a treat!
Next is RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness.
We have another teaser.
It is a brand new 3DCG animation
based on the globally popular
survival horror game Resident Evil.
It is a horror-action story centered
around the popular characters
Leon S. Kennedy and Claire Redfield.
Please enjoy the first CG drama series
on such a titanic scale.
Netflix original anime series
RESIDENT EVIL: Infinite Darkness
will stream worldwide in 2021.
What a lineup!
Please look forward
to Netflix Anime’s lineup in 2021!
Now we move onto the next segment.
-Now we play games.
-This is it.
No skipping segments.
Onto the game segment we go.
We will ask out guests on stage today
to break into two teams.
They will play some games for us.
Please use your acting skills,
imagination, focus, observation,
and skill to read the room
as voice actors to win the challenge!
Shiraishi-san, Kaji-san and Tsuda-san
will be Team Mega.
Team Mega!
Kohno-san, Shimazaki-san,
and Kobayashi-san will be Team Rich.
Team Rich!
Team Mega and Team Rich.
They have a god.
No, no, no. You're all gods.
It's Record of Ragnarok up here.
So true.
The team with more points
will win a prize at the end!
Good luck to the contestants!
Let's get started! What's the first game?
Netflix Doubt!
One team will be the presenter.
The other team will answer.
The presenter will read stories off a card.
However, only one card
has a complete story written on it.
The other two members
only have rough plots.
You must act and try to prevent
the answering team
from guessing who is reading off the card
that has no complete story.
The answering team must guess
which two drew the card with no story.
In other words, guess which two
are making up their story on the spot.
You have one shot to guess correctly.
You guess right,
your team wins 10 points.
The presenters will be tested on their acting skills.
The answering team will be tested
on their observational skills.
I hope you get the answers right.
Let's get started.
Team Mega goes first.
There are three cards on the table.
One card has a complete story.
The other two are rough plots.
Shiraishi-san,
please go up and pick a card.
-I'm nervous.
-Right?
Please take a peek.
You can study her reaction as a clue.
-It's already begun!
-That's right.
-This is tough.
-Really rough.
Take a peek but don't let them see.
What does that mean?
Please return to your seat.
-Was she relieved?
-Was she?
Kaji-san.
Will we find out who has the script?
You'll find out later but not right now.
Take a careful peek.
What does it mean? His acting is superb.
-The game is on!
-Tsuda-san.
Step by step. He takes a a peek.
He's so hot.
-That face.
-Meaningful grin.
-What does it mean?
-So sexy!
When I say observe, I don't mean admire.
This is a game, remember?
The cards are drawn.
Team Mega has 30 seconds to think.
This is your chance to think of your story.
We have an example for the viewers
so they know what to expect.
As you can see, some elements
are included in all three cards.
The opening line,
“My name is Seitaro Mukai!”
You begin here.
The character’s personality,
manner of speech,
title, and closing line.
One person has this
completely filled out card.
The other two only have the outline.
Just the themes.
Team Rich keeps staring at Team Mega.
You're just staring at each other.
Stop waving.
Our eyes met. My heart skipped.
Knock it off.
Are you ready? Let's decide the order.
Team Rich, close your eyes.
Team Mega, decide your order.
I'm OK with anything.
Really?
If you talk there's no point
in them closing their eyes.
You've got to gesture.
You can choose.
Team Rich, please open your eyes.
Will the presenter please stand?
Netflix Doubt Start!
I'm Seitaro Mukai.
Character setting.
Girlfriendless for 35 years.
Currently jobless. I run into a childhood
friend who grew up to be beautiful.
Monologue.
Let's be close like we used to be?
Wha-!? It says, "wha-!?"
The title is
Is a Jobless 35-Year-Old Allowed
to Hang Out With a Hot Girl?
What a title.
The line I have to read.
"Call me Sei-chan like you used to."
Thank you. Very nice.
Can we say the genre? It's romantic comedy.
May we have the second presenter?
Please begin!
My name is Seitaro Mukai!
I'm starting high school today.
They thought I was groping a girl
on the bus on the way to school.
What?
What a rough start to the first day of school.
When I arrive at the classroom
I spot the girl that I groped in the bus!
-You groped her?
-Who accused me, that is.
Our love story begins.
Of course we had no idea back then.
I see.
Title.
-Seitaro Mukai! A Beast In Love
-Beast?
-The line.
"I know you got the hots for me! Fess up!"
Nice. Thank you!
What a hot beast!
-It must be like Beauty and the Beast.
-I see.
Tsuda-san, if you will.
I'm Seitaro Mukai.
I'm 35, from Cuba,
and I'm starting high school.
That's a lot to digest.
My hand touched another on the bus.
He did it.
But it was the back side of my hand.
Still not OK.
It was an accident. I'm sorry.
But I'm Cubano.
-So what?
-I'm a man of passion.
Title.
Man From Cuba.
So straightforward.
The line.
-"Just a little bit."
-Huh?
What a title.
When does he say the line?
-We really captured the characters well.
-Are you sure?
Two out of three were groping people!
It might be what the script said.
What did you think, Team Rich?
Do you want to discuss?
Tsuda-san's line at the end
was suddenly on the receiving end.
That switch had to have come
from Tsuda-san himself.
He was explaining his innocence,
then suddenly he is on the receiving end.
Out of the blue.
That has to be Tsuda-san.
Great analysis.
So you choose Tsuda-san?
-He had a rough plot?
-Yes.
Who else?
Kaji-san wouldn't get the role of the beast
with such a pretty voice.
Sudden criticism?
My feelings are hurt.
I want to be the beast too.
Netflix, please cast me as the beast.
He can play the beast too.
A beast may have a pretty voice.
But this is Kaji-san.
He can do a beast voice if he wants to.
I see.
If he has the script,
he will prepare for it.
That's why I think
his natural hotness came through.
He is naturally too hot.
His hotness overwrote the beast?
Then can we agree on the answer?
That means Shiraishi-san is the culprit!
Culprit?
That's not the game.
Shiraishi-san is the honest one.
The other two are liars.
That's right. She has the script.
You think Kaji-san and Tsuda-san are lying?
-Yes!
-OK.
On my signal, will the people without the script
please show your cards to the camera?
On the count of two. One, two!
There you have it! Team Rich got it wrong!
Team Mega deceived them!
Incredible!
I have a feeling this was all a part of their plan.
I had the script.
-I'm so sorry.
-It's OK.
We fooled you.
-She did a great job.
-Read so smoothly.
It was my plan.
I was wondering what the others would do.
She volunteered to go first.
I followed her lead and pretended
to stumble my lines.
Then Tsuda-san went along perfectly for us.
He made the perfect blend for us.
It's Team Rich's turn.
Please come and get your card.
OK!
They're watching your reaction!
This is important!
There you go!
What was that?
Shimasaki-san.
This is a big clue.
Looking back, you can tell.
He takes a peek.
What is this?
The universe has spoken.
-You have spoken.
-Something is fishy.
Kobayashi-san.
He's already acting.
There's only one card. Just take it!
What could that expression mean?
He looks like he can do housework!
That's got nothing to do with this.
-But he can't cook rice!
-Knock it off.
You can tell all that?
You have 30 seconds to think.
Team Mega, you did so well.
I didn't expect it to work so well.
What was that about Cuba?
It just popped into my mind.
-But you ran with it to the end.
-Yeah.
It even ended up in the title.
Great job.
We had a turn at presenting
so we have an advantage.
We can guess where
the other team might be lying.
Very true.
Team Rich must take that into account.
Team Mega, please close your eyes.
Team Rich, how will you present?
They are deciding. Are you ready?
OK. Please open your eyes.
Team Rich Netflix Doubt, start!
-Who is first?
-Me!
-Kohno-san?
-Yes!
Please start!
My name is Seitaro Mukai!
-I'm five!
-Just a kid!
I often get bullied,
but one day I met Blank-chan!
-I mean, Marika-chan!
-Marika-chan?
I decided to be a hero
to protect Marika-chan!
A Tiny Hero.
Never Fear! I will protect you, Marika-chan!
Thank you!
-They do a hero series.
-All of them?
- I see.
-Her title is "A Tiny Hero"?
-Is it?
-Yes.
Who is second?
Kobayashi-san? Let's begin!
My name is Seitaro Mukai!
I am a super hero that protects this town.
However, no one knows this.
I wear...
Let's see...
-Tights.
-What?
I clad myself in full-body tights
and patrol the town!
You'll get arrested.
I fight an evil entity.
They send one enemy after the other
for me to take down!
Special Attack
Mukai katta!
What's that?
I have protected the peace once again!
The title.
Superhuman
Superhuman Squadron Mukai
Mukai Mask Man
Are you alone or are you a squadron?
Never Fear! No matter what, I will protect you!
Thank you. Nice wrap up.
We had Mukai Kamen Man.
Shimazaki-san, are you ready?
Please read your story.
My name is Seitaro Mukai.
I go to Seija Private High School.
However, it is only a diguise.
I am a dark hero
with memories of my past life.
-I am Justice Blade.
-Justice Blade?
I serve justice with the power of darkness.
The era of serving justice
to evil is over.
Evil judges evil!
It is I, Justice Blade,
who will judge evil!
Witness the story of Justice Blade's
battles in darkness!
Dark hero, Justice Blade.
Say the line with me!
Three, two, one!
"Dark blade cutting through the night!"
What?
Thank you!
There you go. Three hero plots.
Please decide who had the script.
Shimazaki-san wasn't looking at the card.
I already memorized it.
You did?
I did add my own twist to it.
He's lying.
Do you think so?
-Who else?
-I think Kohno-san.
Kobayashi-kun was reading badly on purpose.
But it might be a decoy.
Kohno-san said "Blank-chan,"
then Marika-chan.
Did she read the script wrong and fix it?
Or was that all acting too?
Who will Team Mega choose?
Shiraishi-san will choose.
Well Uh... Shimazaki-san....
And Kohno-san.
I see.
Did Team Mega get it right?
Please show your cards on my cue. One, two!
You fell for it!
Team Mega got it right!
Incredible!
You got it right. Team Rich seems so sad.
I was so nervous I drank the whole bottle.
-They saw through me!
-You didn't read the card!
You couldn't have memorized it.
Team Mega earned ten points.
Team Rich earned zero points.
That’s all for “Netflix Doubt”!
Let’s move on to the next game.
The next game is “Netflix Search”!
This is the last game.
I will read out keywords associated
with a particular anime title.
You must try and guess it.
New keywords will be added
as time progresses.
Press the button as soon
as you know what title it is.
When your lamp lights up,
use the tablet to search for the title.
Then, show it on your screen to answer.
Please press the button after
you have searched the title.
So the titles are streaming on Netflix?
Of course.
I watch Netflix a lot.
I was watching yesterday too.
Good.
You might have an advantage.
If you answer incorrectly, the opposing team
will be given the right to answer.
Please keep that in mind.
Your imagination
and inspiration will be tested.
Each correct answer will earn you five points.
Let's go. Are you ready?
“Netflix Search,” start!
You will get a clue every 10 seconds.
Finger.
Buzz in if you know.
Shimazaki-san!
I watch this.
Your answer please!
Itaewon Class!
No?
Nope.
But this finger!
So much for watching Netflix all the time.
Of course not.
We're talking about anime.
Team Mega can answer now.
-No new clues?
-No.
Please answer as is.
We can move on too.
Shiraishi-san?
This anime!
The Disastrous Life of Saiki K.
Wrong.
It's not about fingers being in the banner.
It's a free for all.
Let's see more clues.
Negative emotions. Finger.
Kobayashi-san. Please answer.
Non Non Biyori.
Not possible.
No negative emotions there.
All happiness. It's a recovery potion.
Mega Team, over to you.
If you don't answer, it's a free for all.
Can you answer?
Kaji-san? Your answer?
-I have to search?
-Yes.
-Is it there?
-No?
Is he timidly playing the piano?
It's not the one I thought.
You're out of time!
You can all answer.
We have a new clue.
High school.
Do you have the screen?
I got inspired by Non Non Biyori.
Really?
Your answer please.
Jujutsu Kaisen!
That's right!
How is that connected to Non Non Biyori?
It's team play.
Wonderful.
Please search the title
then press the button to answer.
The next question is this.
Humanity.
It could be anything.
It could be Non Non Biyori.
Could be.
What's the next clue?
Here it comes.
Heart.
Oh no.
Do you have the screen ready?
Please answer.
Attack on Titan!
Yes!
Dedicate your heart!
Thank you!
I already thought of it at "humanity,"
but it could have been Non Non Biyori.
Could be.
They have hearts too.
But I took a chance.
You won five points.
Next question.
Los Angeles.
What could it be?
Not Non Non Biyori.
Singapore.
Los Angeles. Singapore.
International.
Please get the title ready
then press your button.
London.
Maybe they visit these places.
Shanghai.
Shanghai?
Kobayashi-san, your answer please!
Great Pretender!
Wonderful.
The four locations rang a bell?
Five points! Well done!
Keep it up!
Next question.
Hakone.
Another location.
What is located in Hakone?
14 years old.
Hakone. 14 years old.
-Tsuda-san.
-Evangelion.
Tsuda-san.
-Neon Genesis Evangelion.
-Correct!
So fast!
-That was easy.
-Yes.
You were so fast.
Five points!
What a great battle!
Next question!
The keyword is...
Ship.
Does it ring a bell?
Does Non Non Biyori visit the sea?
No.
Sword.
That was close!
Shimazaki-san, please answer!
One Piece!
Correct!
Yes!
I'm in it! I have to get it right!
Shiraishi-san had it too.
Yes. I had the screen open.
It was so close.
This is like a real quiz show.
On to the next question!
Here it comes.
Vampire.
Vampire. What could it be?
There are many vampire anime.
What's next?
Pillar.
Yes, Tsuda-san?
Demon Slayer!
That's not it!
I know you thought that at "pillar."
You fell right for the trap. Thank you.
This is exactly what we planned for.
You got it wrong so Team Rich
has the right to answer.
Would someone like to answer?
Vampire and pillar?
Not Non Non Biyori.
They don't have vampires.
Your answer please!
Devil's Line!
Anyone can answer. New clue please!
Bow and arrow.
Kobayashi-san.
Jojo's Bizarre Story.
Yes!
Jojo's Bizarre Adventure. Close enough!
Wonderful.
The final question!
The first clue.
- God.
-Tsuda-san?
-No way.
-Me?
A show about him?
Devil.
He's also a devil.
God. Devil.
It can't be Tsuda-san.
Could be it?
Crybaby.
-You could be more confused.
-True.
That's the third clue.
Satan.
Crybaby. Satan.
Is it too hard?
Kobayashi-san, please answer.
-Non Non Biyori.
-No!
Apologize!
They never had Satan!
Mega Team, any takers?
You can take a stab.
You might run out of time.
Crybaby?
We're out of time. New clues please.
Rap.
Dancing won't help.
Director Masaaki Yuasa
How about now?
Shimazaki-san! Please answer.
Devilman.
Yes, that's right!
I thought so.
The protagonist is a crybaby.
That's all with the games.
Let's look at the points.
Team Mega 10 points. Team Rich 25 points.
Congrats Team Rich!
We have the final results.
Team Mega 20 points.
Team Rich 25 points.
Team Rich is the winner!
Congratulations!
Thanks to Non Non Biyori!
I should have taken away points for that!
Congratulations.
The winning team will be presented
with a “Netflix Mega-Rich Happy Bag,”
which is mega-rich
with Netflix original merch!
It's packed! Please look forward to it.
Congratulations!
I hope you enjoyed the game segment!
It's already time for the ending.
How time flies.
Could we have a word from our guests
for our viewers?
Shiraishi-san?
Thank you for watching today.
Thank you for letting me introduce
High-Rise Invasion today.
I am even more excited
about Netflix Anime now.
What's great about Netflix
is that you can binge watch.
Please binge watch
High-Rise Invasion many times.
-Thanks for today.
-Thank you!
Kaji-san?
Thank you for watching.
B: the Beginning is in its second season.
If you watch you'll get hooked.
Today I discovered shows
I'd like to start watching.
Maybe the viewers did too.
I hope you'll deepen
your love for anime too.
Please keep watching Netflix Anime.
Thank you.
Tsuda-san?
I'm Tsuda, a.k.a. god.
Thank you.
The Way of the Househusband
will start streaming really soon.
It'll start April 8th,
so please look forward to it.
It has amazing characters and story.
It's something you can kick back and enjoy.
Like they said,
I got to know new shows tonight.
I'm going to binge watch too.
I think that's what is amazing about Netflix Anime.
Please invite me back
when you have another show like this.
Thank you.
Next, Kohno-san.
I'm Mariko Kohno from Eden!
It's an original series,
so there's not much info yet...
but it's a drama with humans against robots.
If robots had human emotions,
would they try to eliminate humans?
If humans were in that world, what would happen to robots?
It's a thought-provoking series!
Please do check it out!
It was fun to spend time with these "godly" voice actors! Thanks!
Shimazaki-san, please.
You're a voice acting god too!
It was so fun!
And I'm excited to see everyone's shows!
Netflix Anime titles span every genre,
and they're high-quality and interesting.
I want to recommend them to everyone!
As for BAKI, Baki Hanma is coming,
and every previous season is available now.
You could watch them all from beginning to end!
They're all great! Thanks!
Kobayashi-san!
Thanks for watching, everyone!
It was my first time promoting Spriggan at an event.
I hope I was able to communicate its charms a little.
As everyone said, there's tons of great anime on Netflix.
And you can watch anytime.
Before bed, in the bath, while on the train...
And sorry to all the Non Non Biyori fans!
-Sorry!
-I do love it!
There'll be lots more about Spriggan soon.
Please look forward to it!
High-Rise Invasion and B: The Beginning are streaming now.
The Way of the Househusband is coming April 8.
Eden is coming May 27.
Baki Hanma and Spriggan are coming in 2021.
Every show will premiere worldwide at the same time!
Thank you for watching! Goodbye!